we are taught from a young age that
there are words we shouldn't say that's
nice because there are seven [ __ ]
reasons we should swear more don't [ __ ]
bite it there's research that swear
words are the basis of all language kids
often learn where it's fit in class
before they even learn the alphabet and
we do it all King time it is used an
average speech as much as first-person
plural pronouns like R and V it is a
proven pain management tool in one model
between torturous study people put their
hands in freezing water
those that swore could keep their hands
in water for about twice as long
swearing has a special place in the
brain instead of being stored with the
rest of language they are processed deep
on the rights of the brain along with
emotions this fact may help explain why
people with Tourette's sometimes have a
deep urge to swear and also why swearing
feels so [ __ ] good like your car horn
swearing is a fruit and versatile way to
express yourself joy pain surprise you
could say this sucks
or you could say this is really cool and
really get your point across
profanity view can also show we belong
to a certain group and it can signal we
are open honest easygoing and the MUP
looking life of the party
health benefits can include increased
circulation elevated endorphins and an
overall sense of well-being you know you
want to so get to swearing mother Falls
yeah [ __ ] guy let it [ __ ] gay
friend oh yeah oh no I was just like my
life you know